robert de niro has some things to say
about the things other people are saying
about his new movie we're talking of
course of todd phillips joker the
controversial new film from warner
brothers and DC in which De Niro appears
in a major supporting role over the
course of his decades-long career in
cinema De Niro has played everything
from hard-nosed gangsters and bullish
boxers the overprotective fathers and
emotionally damaged war vets he even
threw down against a certain moose and
squirrel duo and a kid-friendly comedy
are you talking to me
no I'm talking about you and I'm the
only one here so you must be talking to
me this year De Niro is charging right
back into the for your consideration
fray with the raw and gritty Joker while
the dark take on the Clown Prince of
Crime seems primed to set the box-office
on fire Joker has also found itself
wrapped up in some surprising
controversy the contention surrounds the
rampant gun violence that plays a part
in Joker's story with violence and
Firearms tending to accompany the Joker
character in whatever form he takes the
perceived content of the movie has
inspired some family members of the
victims of the 2012 mass shooting in
Aurora Colorado which tragically
unfolded during a screening of Warner
Brothers The Dark Knight Rises to pen a
heartfelt letter to the studio prior to
Joker's release they say they're
concerned that Joker may inadvertently
inspire copycat acts of violence this
movie is really fueling the fire force
anyone who might even be thinking about
you know being a copycat for a mass
shooter the group further urged the
studio to lobby for gun reform cease
their support of public figures who
advocate for gun rights and to consider
throwing more support behind groups who
help the victims of gun violence that
letter has left Joker's director cast
and studio in the hot seat as they've
been promoting the movie ahead of its
October 4th release in the last week
alone
Phillips Phoenix and Warner Brothers
have all opened up with their own
particular views regarding the matter
and now chatting to variety during the
red-carpet event for another of his
upcoming films the Irishman
robert de niro finally offered his own
take on the joker controversy de niro
who plays a talk-show host named Marie
Franklin in the film had this to say I
know this controversy and I think some
of the things were being said about
Warner Brothers giving money not
endorsing or whatever was about the NRA
I think he's right
De Niro's words about the Joker
controversy will hardly come as a
surprise to folks who have followed his
work in recent years the actors
unflinching political perspectives and
open criticisms of the American
government an especially President
Donald Trump have made him a target of
politicians and other people who stand
on the opposing side of those views
you've called him a boy peg threatened
to punch him needless to say it's
probably a good thing that he wasn't
quite so frank in response to the Joker
controversy as he's been about other
topics DeNiro wisely didn't use the
moment to grandstand or stump for his
own views instead simply offering his
own support of the Aurora families in
their worries as for the current
controversy the Joker despite always
being shown as a homicidal maniac seems
to inspire a sort of idol worship
mentality amongst his fans the
characters rock star like aura seem to
reach a new level with Heath Ledger's
unforgettable turn as the clown in
2008's The Dark Knight while the
connections between that film and the
actions of the Aurora shooter remain
tenuous many still believe the Joker
served as inspiration for the violent
act as such some believe this new take
on the character may be dangerously
provocative on the other hand plenty of
people see no reason to worry about
Joker at all seeing it as just another
edgy comic-book movie so this may go
down as a case of much ado about nothing
there doesn't appear to be any movement
to stop Joker from being released and
the Aurora families haven't called for a
boycott of the film they simply argue
that if Warner Brothers is going to
profit off fictional gun violence they
would do well to treat the victims of
real gun violence with consideration and
support Warner Brothers remains
steadfast that Joker in no way attempts
to portray Joker as a heroic figure
amidst the controversy the studio is
urging people to withhold judgment until
they've actually seen the film with a
spokesperson recently offering quote a
lot has been said about Joker and we
just feel it's time
people to see the film as for De Niro
aside from the controversy he's had
nothing but positive things to say about
his experiences on Joker as he told to
Variety I like Todd Phillips and Joaquin
they they were terrific to work with
with any luck the energy surrounding
Joker will remain similarly positive and
the film will arrive with little more
than a heavy dose of entertainment value
a dash of societal insight and a stream
of awards season success but of course
we won't get a real sense of how Joker
plays until the film hits theaters on
October 4th here's hoping there are
happy faces all around check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the belt so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]